[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
corinne in est-il présidente de la
confédération des petites et moyennes
entreprises de la région sud provence
alpe côte d'azur bonsoir avec vous ce
soir jean philippe dugoin clément maire
udi de mennecy vice président de la
région ile de france en charge de
l'environnement nous a rejoint également
alexis poulain éditorialistes bonsoir à
tous les trois merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france corinne estime
me tourne vers vous la vente des
produits non essentiels sera donc
interdite dans les grandes surfaces par
souci d'équité on le disait avec des
petits commerces
une mesure qui prendra effet mercredi
puisque le gouvernement a annoncé cet
après midi une tolérance jusqu'à
mercredi dans ces grandes surfaces
finalement le terme équité employés par
le gouvernement
est ce vraiment le cas selon absolument
pas d'ailleurs les témoignages que vous
avez vu tout à l'heure
vont dans le sens de ce que à la cmu
alors moi je suis présidente de la du
départ' de l'âme de mythe et
départementales du 13-mai effectivement
ce que je vous disais c'est que c'est ma
jument majoritairement très mal ressenti
qu'on ne vous permettent pas aux petits
commerçants des trouvères n'avait pas
demandé forcément la fermeture des
rayons non essentiels dans les grandes
surfaces parce que bien évidemment celui
qui en bénéficie
et bien c'est encore une fois amazon ou
douane tous les géants du net
c'est-à-dire que les achats vont se
reporter sur l'achat en ligne
nous nous demandions de prendre en
considération tous ces commerces qui
depuis le premier confinement ont
investi dans les gestes barrières les
équipements sanitaires ont mis
systématiquement place tout ce que le
gouvernement leur a tous choqués de fer
dans les commerces où justement où va en
général en petit nombre
donc on n'a jamais pu prouver non plus
que dans ces commerces
on a pu être contaminées et on les rend
responsables en quelque sorte et le plus
dramatique c'est que c'est à la veille
d'une période charnière pour eux puisque
les achats de noël représente pour la
majorité entre 20 et 60% selon le type
d'activité de leur chiffre d'affaires
annuel
donc c'est vraiment la double peine
cette mise en place de la fermeture
l'amendement a été voté par le sénat et
nous c'est m 13 nous avons beaucoup
insisté auprès des députés parce que
demain le vote à sera dans leurs mains
et on a bien insisté auprès d'eux et on
a vu avec courage pour bien deux maires
ont pris la décision tout en sachant que
ça pouvait être effectivement cassé par
le préfet mais ont montré leur
attachement au commerce juste devant
justement corinne estime on a un maire
avec nous ce soir on va en parler tout
de suite juste avant que vous propose
d'écouter les mots de la ministre du
travail j'entends le désarroi et la
colère des petits commerçants
mais si on ouvre les commerces il n'y a
plus de confinement il faut que chacun
s'empare des outils qui existent mais
continuer à faire ses courses comme
avant comme si de rien n'était ne sera
pas possible dans l'immédiat
plus le confinement sera efficace plus
on pourra rouvrir vite les commerces
alors elisabeth bord mais aussi le
ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire qui ont jugé
irresponsable et maires qui sont montés
au front avec des arrêtés d'ouverture
jean philippe dugoin clément vous êtes
mais rudy de mennecy
comment est-ce que vous réagissez quand
vous entendez ces maires jugés
irresponsables par le gouvernement déjà
je trouve que ces ministres devraient
faire attention en terme qu'il emploie
quand le président de la république
vient encore une fois faire appel aux
maires quand on mesure le poids et
l'importance qu'ont eue les élus locaux
pour essayer de faire en sorte que le
premier confinement se passe bien
la première des responsabilités de la
part de madame bornes monsieur le maire
serait de revenir sur des propos qui
étaient visiblement excessif les maires
ne traite pas les ministres des
responsables d'une question de respect
c'est aussi quelque chose qui doit
exister dans ce pays et respect qu'il
n'existe pas dans les propos de ces
ministres
pour le reste j'ai surtout l'impression
qu'on est en quelque sorte sur on est
dans le monde des shadoks on interdit
les livres on interdit les fleurs les
commerçants indépendants de proximité se
plaignent et c'est normal la
représentante de la ceppm du xiii a
expliqué qu'il n'y avait pas de risque
sanitaire
y a des mesures sanitaires prises
individuellement dans ses magasins et
plutôt que de les autoriser à pouvoir
faire leur travail
on interdit aux grandes surfaces de le
faire si on ne laisse comme seule
solution aux français qui ont besoin de
pouvoir consommer de pouvoir vivre de
pouvoir préparer les fêtes de fin
d'année que d'aller vers les gaffes à
d'aller vers amazon
je crois qu'on est sur quelque chose
d'absolument fou ce gouvernement sur ce
sujet réagi comme souvent depuis le mois
de mars en retard comme il réagi en
retard ils sur-réagissent il se rend
compte qu ils sur réagissent mais il
refuse d'amendé complètement une
sur-réaction pour ne pas perdre la face
moi je crois profondément que dans la
vie en politique également une erreur ça
peut arriver notamment quand on agit
sous la pression quand on agit dans
l'urgence quand on fait face à des
crises mais l'honneur du politique c'est
de savoir revenir sur une erreur c'est
de savoir reconnaître quand il ya une
erreur qu'on a poussé le curseur un
petit peu trop loin qu'il faut revenir
en arrière et tous ces maires moi je
j'ai choisi de ne pas prendre d'arrêté
parce que ces arrêtés sont illégaux
seront systématiquement cassés avec
l'association des maires d'ile-de-france
nous allons attaquer le décret du
gouvernement mais faut bien avoir
conscience que tous ces maires sont tout
sauf des irresponsables tous ces maires
propose des solutions propose d'être les
garants pour permettre à nos commerçants
continuent à vivre ce qu'on est en train
de faire aujourd'hui c'est de créer une
injustice absolument folle c'est de tuer
le commerciaux même pas le commerce de
proximité par le petit commerce le
commerce physique tout simplement au
profil de gaza qui ne crée quasiment pas
d'emploi notre pays qui paye extrêmement
peu d'impôts est vraiment moi je pense
que le mauvais combat le mauvais débat
c'était encore une fois d'essayer
d'arriver d'essayer d'opposer petits
commerces et grandes surfaces on va dire
qu'il ya des grandes surfaces qui ont
ils des gestes de solidarité extrêmement
fort par rapport aux commerçants leur
commune et je crois qu'on est sur
quelque chose on ne doit pas être
divisée
on doit être rassemblé que le rôle du
gouvernement c'est pas d'avoir des
propos exagérés vis-à-vis des mères
c'est pas de traiter ceux qui sont en
désaccord avec lui dit responsable c
effectivement d'essayer d'écouté
d'essayer de travailler ensemble et
d'essayer dans un contexte extrêmement
compliqué et bien tout simplement
pouvoir essayer de protéger l'essentiel
et moi je ne comprends pas comment on
peut nous expliquer aujourd'hui qu'il
n'y a pas de risque à aller travailler
mais qu'on peut pas des chez son
coiffeur qu' il n'y a pas de risque à
pouvoir aller chez un sophrologue mais
que dans le même temps on peut pas aller
acheter des fleurs
on voit bien le niveau de la cohérence
qu'il y a on a un café tabac qui pourra
ouvrir alors qu'un café tout seul ne
peut pas ouvrir enfin on est sur quelque
chose qui est profondément irrationnelle
on voit dans le cadre des auto écoles où
les cours ne peuvent pas être dispensés
mais pour autant on peut faire passer
des examens
on a toute une série d'adaptations à
voir le gouvernement aujourd'hui se
retrancher se cache derrière une date
fixée à quinze jours par le président de
la république
le problème c'est pas 15 jours c'est
aujourd'hui on a des indépendants qui
sont en train de voir leur activité
mourir et ça c'est quelque chose qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas supportable et il
ya une urgence
on ne peut pas attendre 15 jours et je
pense que l'honneur du gouvernement
et bien c'est tout simplement de
s'adapter personne n'a la solution exact
personne n'a la science infuse
on fait face et une crise sans précédent
chacun la découvre petit à petit essaye
de s'adapter mais en général je crois
que l'intelligence collective elle est
plus forte que ce qui se fait à trois ou
quatre dans un cabinet ministériel
alors à vos côté alexis poulenc on
connaît bien sûr rt france vous
intervenez dans un instant juste juste
avant je me tourne vers vous corinne et
nestea cela magasins sur trois un site
internet a regretté le ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire un fonds de
100 millions d'euros pour digitaliser
les petits commerces va être débloquée
est ce qu'aujourd'hui finalement il faut
que les commerces de proximité sans par
l'internet pour exister selon vous est
ce que c'est une piste jouable ou alors
il n'y a qu'une seule martine une seule
alternative finalement ouvrir tous les
commerces au plus vite dès le 13
novembre quand comme le demande des
commerçants alors le n'empêche pas
l'autre bien évidemment nous la demande
c'est que les commerces soient ouverts
le plus vite possible je remercie
d'ailleurs les propos qui viennent
d'être tenus et qui vont justement dans
le sens de ce que nous pensons par
contre vous avez révélé et la crise de
tuco vide a bien révélé que les
commerçants n'étaient pas assez bien
équipé en digitalisation et c'est vrai
que cet homme pas à franchir
donc beaucoup de plateformes sont
comment ça a été de développer nous
mêmes la ceppm 13 nous avons mis en
place
on y travaille depuis deux ans et
justement grâce à l'accélération on a pu
avoir des financements complémentaires
et on le propose à l'ensemble des
commerçants de mai des plates formes en
ligne pour ceux qui ne sont pas déjà
équipés la région bien la région de paca
sud vient également de confirmer qu'elle
met en place une plate forme donc tout
le monde les acteurs économiques les
acteurs locaux se sont emparés bien
évidemment de la solution absolument
nécessaire qui est le mettre en place
cette digitalisation mais ça n'empêche
pas et je le répète que nous demandons
l'ouverture le plus vite possible
surtout dans cette période parce que
qu'est ce qui va se passer
et bien si on ouvre le plus tard plus
vite on ouvrira et moi les effets de la
perte de chiffre d'affaires seront
ressentis parce que les aides c'est
toujours pareil on nous annonce des
aides
je vous avais je vous rappelle encore
une fois que les décrets annoncé surtout
à marseille nous avons connu en
septembre la fermeture la dernière
semaine de septembre fermeture des bars
restaurants les fonds sociaux le fonds
social de solidarité à 10000 euros n'est
toujours pas actée personne ne l'a
aperçu car les décrets ne sont toujours
pas parus donc faut bien comprendre
aussi cette détresse financière qui fait
que non seulement tout le monde
dans un souci de civisme citoyenneté à
respecter les règles
on lui a demandé de respecter mais pour
autant les uns ne sont pas là et les
indes elles doivent aller au delà de la
simple subventions il va falloir
indemniser vraiment le préjudice pour
ces entreprises parce que les petits
commerçants sont tous des indépendants
et vous savez que quand vos salariés
sont ni l'activité
heureusement d'ailleurs le
l'état a mis en place le chômage partiel
il n'y a absolument rien pour le chef
d'entreprise ni rémunération partiel à
l'heure actuelle ni même si
malheureusement et comme nous le
craignons beaucoup de commerçants ou
d'entreprises vont sans doute déposé le
bilan et on le souhaite bien sûr le plus
tard possible
ils n'auront pas de chômage pas
d'allocation pas d'indemnisation
ils devront même supporter les charges
sociales car ils seront non pas une
dette de l'entreprise mais une dette
personnelle
donc tout est assez dramatique et plus
vite le gouvernement autorisera
l'ouverture des commerces et si possible
est maintenant le 13 novembre mieux se
fera et en plus donc je le répète si la
crise permet aux commerçants de passer
une étape qui va leur permettre de
vendre un peu plus en ligne
sachant que bon la digitalisation ces
10% 1 quand même aujourd'hui à gauche
pas tous présentera demain c'est pas non
plus le plus gros chiffre d'affaires
aujourd'hui on a besoin de lien social
nos petits commerçants pourquoi ils sont
si importants parce que c'est avant tout
des valeurs humaines
c'est un lien social effectivement
alexis poule a on vient d'entendre donc
un maire une commerçante on a entendu la
détresse la colère et puis d'un autre
côté il est à cette crise sanitaire ou
au début de ce journal on disait que les
entendait les chiffres un nouveau
nouveau record selon vous quel équilibre
doit entendre le gouvernement
aujourd'hui le gouvernement doit revenir
à la raison
on est en train de vivre une folie
imposé par des technocrates qui sont en
train de faire la guerre au commerce
plutôt que de faire la guerre aux virus
si on était un tant soit peu sérieux le
confinement serait un confinement global
généralisée d'une quinzaine de jours où
les écoles également serait fermée où
tous très fermé là on a l'impression que
c'est les commerces qui sont punis tout
simplement et que le reste de la vie
doit continuer tant bien que mal avec le
télétravail d'un côté mais avec tous ces
écoliers tous ces professeurs tous ces
personnels administratifs qui doivent
assurer la continuité pédagogique qui ne
pourrait être assurée autrement puisque
le plan c'est la digitalisation le plan
de davos du forum économique mondial
c'est ce grétry 7,1 pour pousser les
gens à davantage de services
en ligne et numérique pourquoi on ne met
pas le paquet sur une école justement
qui permettrait ces moments de
confinement nécessaires pour lutter
contre le virus et éviter que les
soignants ne soit submergée à nouveau
parce qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens parce
qu on leur enlevait la capacité à réagir
à des crises de cette ampleur là donc
aujourd'hui on paye tout simplement
l'incurie des gouvernements successifs
et emmanuel macron hérite cette incurie
mais que fait-il plutôt que de réagir
avec bon sens bien il réagi dans une
folie technocratique où on est en train
de regarder produit par produit ce qui
doit être interdits de vente dans les
grandes surfaces
parce que c'est la concurrence libre et
non faussée qui prévoit qui prévaut et
que les petits commerces eux sont
pénalisés mais c'est scandaleux c'est
proprement incompréhensible pour le
commun des mortels pour les commerçants
comme ça a été dit
ceux là n'ont aucun filet de sécurité et
ça a été dit par les ministres ce ne
sera pas tous les mois que le
gouvernement va trouver 15 milliards
pour soi-disant faire l'aumône et des
ses commerces qu'ils sont en train de
plomber volontairement par cette
politique de fou et encore une fois de
kehl confinement parle-t-on j'apprends
aujourd'hui par exemple que les hospices
de beaune vont organiser la vente
physiquement des grands crus le 15
novembre
250 personnes dans un lieu clos les
hospices de beaune
certes c'est un grand moment de culture
c'est la côte d'or etc
mais où est la logique dans les mesures
qui sont proposés et à côté de ça vous
avez encore une fois l'interdiction de
rester statique dans les parcs et
jardins à l'interdiction de se promener
dans les espaces naturels enfin on est
encore une fois en train de vivre un
moment de folie collective et je crois
que les maires ont raison de lutter pour
sauver leur commerce pour sauver leur
centre-ville pour sauver la vie tout
simplement
je crois que les commerçants ont raison
et je les trouve très obéissants très
gentil parce que évidemment on n'a pas
le choix on doit on doit obéir obéir à
ses lois à ces mesures totalement folle
et aujourd'hui la raison à semble avoir
déserté et le gouvernement et
l'opposition
j'attends et je pense que beaucoup
attendent des paroles fortes parce que
non seulement les syndicats de la grande
distribution les syndicats des
commerçants
mais maintenant c'est le rôle aussi des
élus de la nation que ce soit les
députés qu'ils fassent le boulot qu'ils
représentent le peuple et qu'ils
arrêtent d'obéir aux techno aujourd'hui
on dit on n'a pas l'impression que le
gouvernement lutte contre un virus
et qu'il fait à peu près n'importe quoi
pour faire croire qu'ils luttent contre
un virus et qu'il ne soit pas jugé
responsable à la fin compte tenu des
chiffres des morts qui vont s'accumuler
mais si on avait été sérieux depuis mars
on aurait ouvert des lits on aurait
donné des moyens on aurait arrêté de
donner comme ordre à la rs de fermer des
lits sap a été le cas alors sur les
conséquences de cette crise je vous
propose d'écouter frédéric jeanjean
le secrétaire général de l'union des
métiers et des industries de
l'hôtellerie il s'est exprimé hier sur
notre enquête on écoute et puis on
réagit à l'heure actuelle je tire la
sonnette d'alarmé parce que je pense que
d'ici quelques semaines nous allons nous
retrouver avec des émeutes de la faim en
france et je vais vous donner un exemple
très simple il ya quantité de magasins
autour demande établissements où les
vendeurs et vendeuses travail on fixe et
ensuite une grosse part variable
là ce mois ci leurs commerces étaient
ouverts ils vont pouvoir toucher leur
salaire à la fin du mois de novembre
la part variable aura disparu et nous
allons nous trouver avec les chefs
d'entreprises en tpe pme qui eux n'ont
pas le chômage partiel
ils n'ont pas de couverture on leur a
proposé 1500 euros transformable en dix
mille euros
il faut voir la paperasse qui est à
remplir il faut voir les délais nous ça
fait six semaines qu'on nous a promis
tout un tas dead à marseille
quand monsieur veron et monsieur griset
était venu monsieur castex a dit il ya
une semaine de sart lundi matin et mardi
au plus tard
on attend toujours les décrets monsieur
le maire des émeutes de la faim
à l'avenir c'est une perspective que
vous craignez vous aussi des émeutes je
ne sais pas mais je crois qu'on peut
avoir un phénomène de refus un phénomène
quasi insurrectionnelle ou team gilet
jaune puissance
5 10 15 20 la réalité aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on est fan on est le pays occidental
dont le taux de confiance dans son
gouvernement sur la gestion du comité le
plus faible
on est sur un pays dont le taux de
confiance la cote de popularité du
président du premier ministre du
gouvernement est l'un des plus faibles
on est dans un pays où il n'y a plus de
contre-pouvoirs institutionnels vous
l'évoquiez tout à l'heure concernant le
parlement mais les grands pouvoirs et
les gros contre pouvoirs institutionnels
n'existe quasiment plus dans notre pays
est aujourd'hui on sent monter une forme
de colère et je crois que sur ce point
des commerçants c'est vraiment une
erreur politique majeure majeur qui a
été fait parce que c'est ressenti comme
une injustice et incompris et pour être
respectées ou pour pouvoir être toléré
quand il n'est pas populaire
un gouvernement un pouvoir eh bien il
doit minima ne pas paraître injuste et
là il ya un sentiment d'injustice qui
est extrêmement fort et qui est en train
de se créer et c'est pour ça que je
pense qu' il serait important pour le
gouvernement mais pour notre pays de
revenir là dessus
ensuite je vous disais moi vraiment mon
sens samedi matin j'étais dans ma
commune j'étais au marché je faisais le
tour des commerçants qui pour ceux qui
pouvaient encore être ouvert
j'ai vu énormément de d'habitants qui me
parlait de cette peur qui me parlait de
cette colère qui gronde et aujourd'hui
on sent bien qu'ils aient un phénomène
qui calme cette colère une espèce de 2,2
couvercle sur la marmite c'est la peur
parce qu'il ya une peur global qui est
logique de la pandémie du risque de la
maladie pour soi pour ses proches pour
les autres je suis extrêmement inquiet
de ce qui va arriver dans quatre cinq
six mois quand on sera en mars avril mai
qu'on sera je l'espère sortie de cette
pandémie que notre pays comme beaucoup
d'autres contrats ces morts que notre
pays comme beaucoup d'autres cherchera
les responsabilités et qu'on aura des
centaines de milliers de français qui
vivront un déclassement social parce que
le chômage partiel viable un moment
offert le payer les entreprises qui vont
fermer qui vont baisser le rideau
il va bien falloir l'assumer et moi ce
qui me terrifie
c'est la potentialité d'une réaction
violente au printemps quand on sera
sorti de la crise sanitaire d'une france
massivement des classes et qui aura
perdu toute confiance en ses élites et
sur des choses qui relève du symbole de
la capacité d'acceptation d'un pouvoir
qui relève du sentiment de justice ou
d'injustice
je crois vraiment qu'il faut que le
gouvernement entende entende sa
population entendre les élus qui ne sont
au fond que la voix des territoires et
fasse très très vite machine arrière sur
ce sujet en mettant toutes les
conditions sanitaires s'il faut durcir
des protocoles les commerces se sont ré
le faire les maires centre et en êtes
les garants sont prêts à s'investir
davantage la question n'est pas d'être
irresponsable de dire n'y a pas de
risque est que de lire le code ne tue
pas mais on est dans une situation où je
pense que le corps social français n'est
pas n'est plus en étable subir quelque
chose qu'il considérerait une injustice
surtout quand tu ne vois pas les
résultats
merci à tous les trois d'avoir échangé
en direct ce soir sur notre antenne
merci à vous corinne in est-il
présidente ces pme très c'est la
confédération des petites et moyennes
entreprises merci à vous jean philippe
dugoin clément mais rudy de mennecy vice
président région ile de france en charge
environnementale et merci à vous alexis
poulain éditorialistes